Supernatural monsters are
on the loose! Practitioners
of the Arcane Arts are here to bring about
the end of the world! Sinister paramilitary
forces are using paranormal objects to gain
an edge over their enemies! In short, things
are messed up, and when the anomalous is out
of line, we all know that there’s only one
group you’d ever think to call: The FBI’s
Unusual Incidents Unit.
What, were you expecting someone else?
Everybody knows that the Unusual Incidents
Unit is the goto when it comes to paranormal
deterrence. Sure, they don’t have the resources
of the SCP Foundation. They don’t have the
strategy of the Global Occult Coalition. They
don’t have the ruthlessness of the Chaos
Insurgency, or the arcane knowledge advantages
of the Serpent’s Hand. But they’ve gotta
have something, right? Right!?
Okay, maybe you’re not convinced, but you
will be! You may not respect them yet, but
you’ll change your tune when you find out
that the Unusual Incidents Unit has dealt
with one of the most important anomalies out
there: SCP-001. Or as the true experts over
at the UIU call it, CA3, short for “Confirmed
Anomaly 3.” If the evidence and files put
together by the UIU are to be believed - and
who are we kidding? Of course they are! - then
they may have the answer to one of the anomalous
world’s biggest questions: How was the SCP
Foundation actually formed?
But before we jump into the mysteries of CA3,
let’s talk a little bit more about the real
heroes of today’s story, the UIU. This secretive
offshoot of the FBI - America’s premier
domestic intelligence agency - was personally
commissioned by J. Edgar Hoover during the
Cold War. Why? For the same reason that literally
everything happened in the US during the Cold
War: To get an edge over the Soviets! Hoover
was an extraordinarily powerful man in US
politics, his tenure as FBI Director spanning
the terms of eight different presidents. If
he wanted to start a unit of agents whose
sole job was investigating the supernatural,
nobody would dare stand in his way.
Everyone always talks about the nuclear arms
race going on back in the 1960s, but far fewer
people talk about the supernatural arms race
that was happening at the exact same time.
World War II coincided neatly with the Seventh
Occult War - an important geopolitical event
that played a huge role in shaping the Global
Occult Coalition - and a number of high-ranking
members of the Nazi party were believed to
be key figures in this secret, magical war.
When the Soviets sacked a number of German
cities as part of their offensive campaigns
in World War II, they were able to bring back
scores of anomalous items that the Nazis had
been using to consolidate dark power. This
didn’t bode well for the United States Government
during the Cold War. After all, the only thing
scarier to them than Communists were Magical
Communists! The US needed to build up its
own anomalous arsenal, and that’s where
the UIU came in.
The FBI allocated some of its okayest personnel
to the task. Most were either agents who had
experienced a paranormal encounter out in
the field, or who were being punished for
some kind of heinous mistake they’d made
carrying out their duties elsewhere. Despite
not being the best of the best, these agents
sure were eager to get their hands on some
cans.
That isn’t an innuendo, by the way. The
Foundation refers to anomalies it deals with
as SCPs, or “Skips”, the GOC calls them
Parathreats, and the UIU calls them Cans,
again short for “Confirmed Anomalies.”
Well, when it’s an anomalous event or location,
anyway. Anomalous objects, like cursed books
or supernaturally powerful weapons, are referred
to as “Carts”, or “Confirmed Artifacts.”
And finally, anomalous people or sentient
entities are referred to by the unfortunate
name of “Can Man.”
It may not sound as cool, but hey, it gets
the job done just fine in the end.
While the Unusual Incidents Unit may lack
the knowledge, strength, resources, and even
cred of its fellow groups of interest, that
doesn’t mean that it doesn’t keep track
of the others. In fact, the UIU has a pretty
unique relationship with each of them.
The GOC, for example, is nicknamed “The
Suits” by the UIU. The official UIU orientation
states that the Suits outrank them, and if
they’re asked to follow an order by a member
of the Suits, they should just go ahead and
do it. Same goes for members of The Fireworks
- which is the UIU lingo for the Chaos Insurgency.
Unlike the Foundation, which generally has
the resources to go toe to toe with the Chaos
Insurgency, the UIU are rightfully terrified
of them. Official orders from the top are
for UIU agents to do whatever they say, or
they might find themselves getting shot in
the head by a Chaos Insurgent, or worse.
Next, the Cart Shoppers, also known as Marshall,
Carter, and Dark, a sinister gentleman’s
club and auctioneer of anomalous items. Official
protocol is to raid any deals being conducted
by Marshall, Carter, and Dark, but oftentimes
these raids are unsuccessful, because M C
and D’s security force are more competent
fighters than anyone on the Unusual Incidents
Unit Payroll.
On the other end of the spectrum are The Can
Collection, the official UIU nickname for
the Serpent’s Hand. UIU Leadership recommends
against their agents staging any one-on-one
confrontations with them. Official memos also
contain the phrase “If they give you an
order, consider following it, they can probably
set you on fire with their mind.”
And finally, the most important relationship
of all is the one they have
with the SCP Foundation.
Much like the rest of the groups of interest
on their roster, the UIU is subordinate to
the SCP Foundation, their agents happily taking
orders from them at the drop of a hat. They
call the Foundation the Skippers, but don’t
let the casual name fool you. The SCP Foundation
is so far above them on the pecking order
that they rarely even communicate in any official
capacity.
When the Foundation talks to the UIU, it’s
always through code. They wouldn’t dream
of letting a hapless UIU agent help them on
any major operation, but lazier agents of
the Foundation might occasionally outsource
work to UIU agents. If ever one of these plucky
feds receives a message starting with, “Hey
Skipper”, they can be sure they’re about
to have a low-priority anomalous case pawned
off on them.
The UIU are so subservient to the SCP Foundation
that it has sometimes
resulted in truly humiliating
mix-ups. One high-ranking member of the UIU
once took orders from a pizza delivery guy,
because he thought the pizzeria’s name,
the Spiced Crust Pizzeria, which could be
shortened to SCP was actually a coded plant
sent by the Foundation to deliver a message,
rather than a deep dish pepperoni and cheese.
Incidents like this are why nobody takes the
UIU seriously.
But according to them, there was a time before
all this. That time ended on September 7th,
1954, when CA3 - or SCP-001, as the Foundation
would later call it - first appeared on the
UIU’s radar. It seemed to be the most standard
Can you could possibly imagine: An anomalous
high school building causing a disturbance
in the suburbs of small town America.
The UIU received the call after a number of
students claimed the interior of their school
suddenly looked completely different than
it ever had before, despite there being no
records of an official remodel. And we’re
not just talking about moving furniture and
a new coat of paint, either.
The official CA3 file logs a number of changes.
These include, but are not limited to, all
the walls in the building
becoming steel-reinforced
concrete. All the windows being blacked out
from the inside. All student desks, personal
effects, textbooks, and any other standard
equipment left inside the
school simply disappearing
in the night. The entire floor plan of the
building seeming to have shifted, with rooms
altering in both dimensions and location,
as well as featuring
seemingly random modifications
within. None of this matched up the building’s
original blueprints, which were obtained by
the UIU shortly after the Can was reported.
But things got even stranger for investigating
UIU agents. The building now contained seventeen
computers,
each with state-of-the-art magnetic-core
RAM and advanced cybersecurity. For a suburban
high school in 1954, it goes without saying
that this was extremely impressive. But weirdest
of all was the fact that a large and seemingly
impenetrable steel wall had appeared in the
auditorium, blocking it off and leaving whatever
was taking place on the other side a complete
mystery. Naturally, the UIU did what little
they could to investigate the matter.
The first investigation group they sent inside
- Team CA3-O5 - never came back out. And Team
CA3-O6, the team they sent in to locate and
retrieve the first team, also disappeared
within the anomaly. Classic UIU expertise
at work.
Almost a month after discovery and initial
containment, a strange noise began emanating
from the auditorium. Shortly after that, the
building became filled with people, all walking
around and working at different operations.
Eerily, everyone there had a resemblance to
members of Team CA3-O6, the rescue team sent
in to save the twelve members of CA3-05, all
of whom were still unaccounted for.
Three months later, the strangeness escalated.
More noises came from the auditorium, and
the anomalous people inside the building had
gathered around the steel wall within. There
was a hole in the wall, six feet in diameter,
and every three minutes for several hours,
the people in the room would appear to simply
pull an anomalous object out of it.
The items were then carried away, and placed
in one of the many rooms
that used to be classrooms,
before being locked up.
The people within the building then seemed
to start guarding these strange items. Others
started performing tests, with what seemed
like far more advanced technology and methods
than what was possessed by the UIU during
the 1950s. What was going on here?
A few days later, several armed guards exited
the building and began guarding the perimeter.
When UIU personnel attempted to lead an assault
on these guards, they were quickly overpowered,
even when advancing with vastly superior numbers.
Whether this was due to the skill of the guards
or the incompetence of UIU agents is still
very much an open question.
Though strangely enough, intel bleeding out
from the inside confirmed that the people
within were treating their anomalous items
with UIU containment and testing protocols
- which is consistent with the knowledge that
CA3-O5 would have had. It seemed almost as
though O5, or copies of O5, were creating
a new splinter organization from within.
And soon enough, it wasn’t just confined
to the interior of the CA3 building anymore.
CA6, a Can Man that the UIU had been tracking
outside the school, was suddenly kidnapped
and shoved into a black car by two assailants
who appeared identical to Agent Dixon - a
man who’d been a member of Team CA3-O6.
The black car then returned to the CA3 facility,
and was allowed to enter into the complex
by the armed guards. CA6 was then removed
from the car by the Dixon clones, and placed
into containment in one of the classrooms.
It wasn’t long after that that the anomalous
people within the CA3 facility made direct
contact with the UIU outside. They sent a
message in morse code on May 1st, 1965. The
people sending the message identified themselves
as the O5 Council - a name that seemed to
be taken directly from the O5 recon team sent
into the facility months ago. They identified
the new organization that they’d constructed
within the confines of the CA3 facility: The
SCP Foundation. They’d just opened their
very first containment site.
This new Foundation expressed the desire to
become allies with the Unusual Incidents Unit,
but sadly for them, it was essentially the
last time they’d ever really be relevant.
If this Foundation origin story is to be believed
- and as with all entries under the title
SCP-001, it’s worth taking it with a healthy
dose of skepticism - then the UIU witnessed
the birth of the organization that would quickly
go on to outperform and overshadow them.
A big win for humanity in the quest to secure,
contain, and protect ourselves from dangerous
anomalies, but another L for the UIU.
Now go check out “SCP-001 - Which is the
Real 001?” and “SCP-001 - When Day Breaks”
for more journeys into the endless mysteries
of SCP-001!